want to know what Pinhead looks like
underneath all those pins we've got such
sights to show you
it was only a matter of time until
Hellraiser got the reboot treatment
after all there aren't many classic
horror IPS left that haven't been
reimagined for modern times arguably
Hellraiser could benefit from a reboot
as the original franchise went off the
rails long before it had the chance to
realize its full potential instead of
making the most of Clive Barker's unique
mythology the sadistic Saga churned out
a series of underwhelming sequels that
were barely connected to the Hellraiser
lore who would have guessed this would
refer to the feeling of watching the
sequels pain has a face
allow me to show it to you while it
remains to be seen if the new movie will
spawn sequels that take the franchise to
new heights fans can rest assured
knowing Hulu's upcoming slice of
xenobite centric chaos has such sights
to show us the filmmakers certainly
aren't interested in recreating Barker's
1987 original film as evidenced by the
casting of Jamie Clayton as the
terrifying sadomasochistic demon Pinhead
the original hell priest was brought to
life by Doug Bradley and his
performances solidified both him and the
character as Bonafide horror icons the
new take on Pinhead is quite a departure
from Bradley's version and early
Hellraiser trailer suggests that Clayton
has made the role her own in the best
way possible Jamie Clayton is
unrecognizable in the new Hellraiser
boasting black eyes pale skin scarred
flesh and pins sticking out of her head
she doesn't look human at all however
the performer behind the pins and
grotesque demonic makeup is actually
gorgeous in Real Life television
aficionados will know her from shows
such as sense8 which saw her play in
lgbtq hacktivist and political blogger
named Nomi marks elsewhere Clayton is
known for her performance as Sasha
Booker on designated Survivor and Tess
Vandenberg on the L word generation q
but now that she's had the opportunity
to play a horror icon Pinhead might be
the role she's most synonymous with
moving forward in many ways Jamie
Clayton's Pinhead is a throwback to the
original hell priest and Clive Barker's
Novella of the Hellbound heart which the
original Hellraiser has adapted from the
xenobites are often described in
androgynous terms so making this version
of Pinhead a little less masculine makes
perfect sense however David Bruckner has
also promised fans that Clayton's
Pinhead will be unlike any previous
iteration of the character while
speaking to Entertainment Weekly the
Hellraiser director confirmed that the
new Pinhead is a complete reimagining
and praised Clayton's performance he
said we knew we wanted Pinhead to be a
woman Jaime was just the right person
for the role a person's identity can be
really exciting for a role in many ways
but I have to emphasize that Jamie me
absolutely killed that's how we got
there additionally Bruckner wasn't
interested in having Clayton copy Doug
Bradley's Pinhead as the English actor
has already perfected that iteration of
the character he added we didn't want to
do a Doug Bradley impression we just
didn't think that's possible to do there
will be suffering but you're going to
get a sense of what pinhead's desires
might be in a way that hits a little
different Pinhead will be appearing in
your nightmares when Hellraiser drops on
Hulu next month